today we're here to honor the legacy
symbols are nothing without the women
and men that give them meaning
we need new heroes the falcon in the
winter soldier is relevant and gripping
in all the right ways
marvel has brought feature film caliber
storytelling to disney plus
superheroes cannot be allowed to exist
original series now streaming only on
disney plus
sam shouldn't have given up the shield
good to see you too buck
not bigger things to worry about
i'm coming with you no you're not let me
hear you if we do this
we're gonna do it our own way let me
hear you
why didn't you use the metal armor right
handed
original series now streaming only on
disney plus
the last time we see sam and bucky is
after steve
leaves the shield with sam sam is coming
to terms with what it's going to be to
pick up that shield
and that's where we kick off the show
the legacy of that shield is complicated
when disney plus was announced there was
an opportunity to interweave the
cinematic universe with a television
university
the world of the falcon winter soldier
in the film is so big
and you want this show to feel as big
and as engrossing
i think fans will definitely get a kick
out of seeing the continuation of that
kind of
filmmaking that those movies had sam
this has to be subtle got it
the action side is so embedded in what
the mcu
is but through the show we wanted to
look at the human side of the characters
for bucky it's the legacy of the winter
soldier his anchor point to the person
who knew him before he was a murder
machine
no longer exists so bucky feels unmoored
in the series and is looking for his
purpose and sam wilson is very much
doing the same thing and steve first
told me about the shield
the first words i said were feels like
it's someone else's
i felt like we would be dishonest just
on a human level
if we had this black man just accept the
symbol without having real
ambivalence about it with this series
we've been able to give a level of
sincerity and humanity to them
you get a real sense of what this
character sam wilson really
is the notion of what blackness means in
america ties very much into sam's
journey
through the events of the show there's a
fight out there and then there's our
fight here
and bro you have taken them both on
[Music]
well let's get to work
the scope of these six episodes is
really amazing i mean it's a huge story
falcon and winter soldier aren't really
vibrant and electric characters
so when you are thrust into the action
you sink into the narrative and where
the story ultimately goes
you